okay i should be live
uh i hope i am if someone can ask a
question you never know with this uh
technology here
um today i want to talk about content i
want to share what where what i'm doing
and hear back from you about what you're
doing as we proceed on our 90-day
challenge
don't be shy about asking questions in
languages other than
english and if you want me to say
something in the language other than
english if i can speak that language i'm
happy to do so
and of course
so i try to do something every day all
right this is the 90 day challenge
but but at the same time i i sort of
caught myself saying i don't want to put
too much pressure on myself to achieve
more than what i can achieve
um
because you know language learning is a
slow gradual process you can't force it
it's more a matter of just putting in
some time regularly without putting too
much pressure on yourself and gradually
you will see the results and they won't
be immediate
um
now
a big issue to me in language learning
is content
content is the teacher
and uh
so i'm struggling right now today i'm
going to talk about arabic i was going
to show you the ipad but again
you know i had this time slot depending
on what else i have uh going on i wasn't
able to test out the ipad i don't want
to have any more
technical glitches so i'm going to stay
with
sharing with you my screen
in arabic um but uh in fact maybe i'll
just show you the screen now
so screen share
screen here start screen share
all right
so you should be able to see my screen
so um
there we are so you know
add link now we have
if i look at the lesson feed i can see
what other people have been studying
uh i may or may not be interested in
this
uh you know i can go to the news feed
here
and i can find news articles
in the case of arabic we only straight
from al jazeera
scraping means that link has the ability
to go to a website
news website and import automatically
that content into link just for the
individual use
of that user so we're not sharing it in
the library
so it's not in violation of any
copyright
but i know if i look at these al jazeera
articles i know from experience that
it's simply too much
for me so if i
if i uh you know what i'm talking about
here is is developing a content
strategy
that works for me
if i'm in a language like french italian
spanish english there's just lots of
content and you can find content that's
not too difficult and still interesting
it's written in the in an alphabet that
you're familiar with it's not difficult
to do
however
in arabic of course it's a i'm still
getting used to reading the arabic
alphabet
and of course there are no freebie words
every word is a
brand new word to learn you can't
you know it's not like
uh the word uh content is gonna work in
spanish and french and portuguese and
italian that's not the case in italian
in excuse me in in arabic so if i open
one of these
so this is now being imported into link
and as soon as the article is in
i will close the pop-up here
so we see actually
there are quite a lot of words here that
i have already saved
so i am making some progress
but
realistically
that one is fine but uh
hassan
okay that's the guy's name
so if it's a guy's name
hassan raanani then i would of course
say no
take with here hassan
no asima
and uh
because it's a name so i don't want
names cluttering up my statistics
but still i find it difficult to read
it's i can do it i can make my way
through of course this is just a
newspaper article there is no no um
audio for this
if i go to if i open another tab
i have two uh
tabs going and i go to my lessons
uh
where
i have so as you can see actually if you
look at the lessons that i've been doing
so i alternate you see i open this al
jazeera which i am going to read
and it'll be tough 20
new words
uh
most recently i went back to my mini
stories because
you know they're comfortable it's easy
and and i'm still
getting used to reading the alphabet so
i'm reading stuff that i'm familiar with
and it's helping me read and then i did
a few lessons in asimil
lessons which i had transcribed for me
but i must say that the arabic
the stories in the assimil are quite
uninteresting to me
and then i had actually it was a very
interesting interview here and we can
open it here
on france.
where i do have the audio
and it's an interview
with a person now this is going to take
a while to open up because it has a lot
of audio
uh interview on trance vancouver with a
palestinian who was going to run for
mayor in jerusalem
so it's quite interesting um to hear the
palestinian perspective
on
what's happening in
israel and the different options that
palestinians have in terms of
protecting their rights and furthering
their cause so the content is inherently
interesting but there's a lot of these
so-called yellow words those are not
words that i know necessarily those are
words that i have looked up
and that i'm still in the process of
learning i mean i have 529
links there that means that i have
looked these words up but by no means do
i know them and there's so many there
that in effect it becomes very very
tough and when i listen to the audio
i really don't understand it there are
parts that i understand in parts that i
don't understand so i end up kind of
back and forth between uh
you know difficult content easier
content the smell is kind of
intermediate content
and uh
the compelling content is tough
one bit of news
i discovered because if we get back to
if we get back to uh
you know content sources of content
al jazeera and france vancat now i paid
to have this transcribed
the frostman cat has a lot of arabic
interviews and podcasts so does al
jazeera
but they come without transcripts
so
i discovered
that there's a site called vocalmatic
actually i found two sites
that provide automatic transcription
one of them
gave me a transcription into arabic but
it was all left to right
so that wasn't going to work
but these people
gave it
right to left which was fine but then i
had as you can see i had an exchange
here
with them
in chat
because
i loaded one
file and that worked and then i couldn't
load the second file and i kept on
getting error messages
and
but eventually i will get this
solved and and
the fact and i think the cost of it was
like for thirty dollars a month
i was entitled to
five hours
of transcript
five hours is a lot for me i mean
because that's each of these interviews
that france vancouver
you know this interview here
where was it this is about a 12-minute
interview
uh it keeps me busy for a long time you
know i'm a good week on this or longer
so if i have five hours a month
of transcribed podcasts
uh that's more than i can handle and uh
so i mean to me that's a good investment
versus
you know however many lessons i could
get for thirty dollars uh you know on
skype
this is a lot of useful content and i i
think the whole
area of podcasts and now our ability at
link to
to bring in um
you know videos you can basically we
have a our
import extension that enables you to to
basically import any video that has uh
subtitles and bring that in as learning
content that link so that you can read
the text and save words and then watch
the video and then take the sound away
with you and listen to it
again this opens up the whole youtube
area unfortunately i haven't found any
arabic movies with arabic subtitles so
it doesn't help me in arabic i'm not
sure if that's available in farsi
but
this
transcription service if i can resolve
whatever technical problem we have here
they
they also provide transcription for
farsi or for persian i'm going to call
it persian from now on so i just signal
that to you because i think
one of our
you know if i look at what matters in
language learning
uh content is is big
uh
so i'm gonna i'm gonna save these
questions please ask your questions i'm
gonna continue talking a bit about
content and then i will start answering
questions
i was talking to someone who was
involved in some uh english language
schools in toronto
and uh they offered
they had both immigrants who paid very
little and then foreign students who
paid a lot to study at school foreign
students got access to a
sort of an online learning tool
but apparently the online learning tool
just consisted of exercises and drills
and fill the blanks and stuff like that
and i must say that all of those kinds
of workbook drill exercises things i
don't find that very useful what i think
is absolutely essential is content
if if
teachers or if somehow we can be
directed to content that really works
for us because it's interesting and it's
just a little bit difficult for us it's
at the right level or maybe we have a
strategy that we very difficult with
easy and stuff like that that's going to
get us there faster and that's why i
think this kind of automatic
transcription services is great
uh
and so that
yeah but at any rate there is a lot of
content out there uh al jazeera i'm
going to go through this article
uh but content is king
and uh
and you know and we do spend a lot of
time i find that i spend a lot of time
uh
getting the content like this is quite
an exercise here to to find
the uh you know the the even here like
if i go to the front cat
uh
site is i find it difficult to figure
out where their podcasts are and then i
go to
itunes and and it just takes and then
once i find the uh
the podcast then how do i actually get
that
uh url or how do i get that file because
the file
is uh the file is not necessarily an mp3
format so then i got to go and find some
way of converting it into mp3 format i
do have that in fact itunes will confirm
convert it into mp3
so there's a lot that goes into and then
of course if i have to have it
transcribed and stuff like that so i
think
i find that
and of course you can also say that
going to bookstores and seeing what's
there
is also part of that whole finding the
content the actual grammatical
explanations
they're readily available if i want to
google you know
persian verbs
russian
noun declensions i mean it's all there
there are great pdf grammars that you
can download so the information about
the grammar is readily available
what's less
easy to get your hands on
a lot of the time is
really good
motivating helpful content with both
audio and text we have a lot of link but
but very soon if you know if we're
interested in a particular subject it's
not obvious that uh you know that the uh
that the feed here
at link is going to be uh
of stuff that that that you're
interested in although it does
very often it suggests things that might
be of interest
but uh
yeah it's uh sometimes you gotta go and
explore on your own now a couple of
questions here so uh so i should
finish off by the way i'm staying on
arabic so just to let you know what i'm
doing and you guys can do whatever
you're doing but i'm going to when we
finish this i'm going to read through
probably read through that al jazeera
article
and
then i have a discussion at 11 with
dahlia
and i've asked dahlia i sent her a copy
of that article
about the palestinian who was planning
to run for mayor of jerusalem
because dalia is originally from
palestine
and although she lives in the states
and maybe if we talk about that article
and there's some aspects of the
the arabic that one of the people in the
interview uses that strikes me as a bit
strange might be palestinian she might
know about that so we're going to talk a
bit about that
interview and i'm staying on arabic i
was on arabic yesterday today tomorrow
and then around noon on wednesday i'm
going to switch back to persian and i've
decided to stop calling it farsi i'm
going to call the language persian
because i just find that that the word
farsi is how they say persian in
their language but in english we call it
persian
all right a couple of questions how to
turn your passive vocabulary into active
vocabulary
um
first of all there is a natural process
whereby
the more you listen and the more you
have
read
and seen words in a variety of contexts
the more
confident you become
as to the meaning of these words how
they're used which other words they're
used together with
and words and especially phrases i like
saving phrases and and looking at
phrases then that you start to want to
use them because they become a part of
you they're bouncing around in your
brain especially if you do a lot of
listening
and i think active vocabulary usually
refers to speaking because when we are
writing we can look things up we don't
have to have the word there you know on
the spot immediately handy and in fact
if we you know if we can speak we cannot
we can also write it down so the issue
is getting to where you can use these
words in your speaking
uh so first thing is that that lots of
content lots of listening is going to
help you
uh the second thing i find that
i have never gotten to speaking as
quickly as now
and and i ascribe that to the mini
stories because there's so much
repetition of vocabulary and repetitive
listening to these stories which in turn
have a lot of repetition
uh
that has really helped me
uh
you know get to
uh where i can speak
and the other thing you have to remember
is that whoever you're speaking to if
they're a native speaker they will
always have a larger
active vocabulary
than you have and you have therefore
it's a good idea to have a large passive
vocabulary so you can understand what
people are saying and you will have a
smaller active vocabulary that you can
use to uh you know defend yourself so to
speak um
maybe i uh you're let's stop screen
sharing so that i can
look at you here
all right yeah so there we are so the
question is
uh just a second here i'm going to do
something
take this over here
all right
so
and one other thing with with uh
converting stuff into active vocabulary
when you start speaking you struggle you
struggle to remember things that you
know that you know
so that the act of speaking itself helps
you convert words into
active vocabulary
that means you have to be willing to uh
deal with the uncomfortable situation of
not being able to say what you want to
say that you can't express all the
thoughts that you have you can't sound
so intelligent because you can't find
the words and just have to keep on doing
it so comes a point when you have a
sufficient
base sort of of a passive vocabulary you
just have to start speaking and speaking
a lot
so
basically converting
passive interactive
point number one
uh accumulate as large as sort of a base
of passive vocabulary as you can lots of
listening and reading
be
you know focus on phrases get used to
the words
three
use or see i guess use the many stories
listen to them many many times as a lead
up to speaking
and then when you feel you're
ready to speak
speak a lot and you will gradually get
better and that's all and and basically
congratulate yourself for whatever
you're able to do and don't worry about
what you weren't able to do
uh okay
do you ever find someone to help you
write and transcribe books
okay
uh i mean books that's a lot uh you know
it would be ideal if you could just
you know
have something that automatically
transcribed audio into into scripts so
that you can learn from it and that's
what i've been looking for so that's
where i
googled automatic transcription for
arabic that's what i googled and a
number of sites came up
the first one i tried it worked but
the arabic went from uh left to right
like english so i couldn't use that and
then i tried another site and it seemed
to work but now i have trouble uploading
files so hopefully we can resolve that
issue but i think increasingly there are
going to be services where you can
automatically transcribe audio
creating transcripts
which are ideal for language learning
because obviously if you have a live
conversation which is then transcribed
that's more alive than say an article
which you have someone record for you
where it's written first and then
uh record it so yeah i'm starting to do
in the past i have paid people to
transcribe
uh audio
uh that's how i got some of the asmil
material into my account at link i did
that for romanian
i've did that i've done that for other
languages but now if there's automatic
translation or excuse me automatic
transcription services available that's
of course much more economical than
paying people to transcribe by hand
now
what would you say the minimum
is for saying that you speak a language
minimum
sort of level mm-hmm
ah
you know i think you can say uh
i i guess
like i say that i speak
say 17 or 18 languages
realistically
uh i can i can easily switch into maybe
10 or 12 of them
so i can speak right now somebody came
at me uh
you know
you take a language like korean here in
palm springs where
at a golf facility where there are a
bunch of korean
golf semi-pro type people
working out practicing and so i chat
with them and
i mean they're very impressed with my
korean i
recognize how inadequate my korean is
however
in a situation of necessity i can speak
uh i have quite a large passive
vocabulary
can i say that i speak korean i might be
real but i end up saying i do so
if if i guess the simple answer would be
if you are a b-1 on the european
uh scale if you're no longer in that
sort of beginner stage if you are in a
b1 stage i think you can say that you
speak the language you can't say that
you're fluent in the language i think b2
is fluent it's not perfect but it's
fluent so in the if for those of you who
are familiar with or maybe not familiar
with the european scale there's a b and
c a is beginner b is intermediate and c
is advanced so the c those people are
very proficient like i consider myself
to be a c level in french
close to c in
japanese but i would struggle with
reading literature in japanese for
example
but let's say with chinese and japanese
i'm at a high b2 level i'm fluent
um
but if you're b1 i think you can say
if you're a starting intermediate you
can say you speak the language if you're
a b2 and by the way i think the distance
from b1 to b2 is huge huge to going from
where you can just say i speak the
language to where you are fluent in the
language and bear in mind that some
people are going to be maybe
better at reading and also good at
speaking or better reading not so good
at listening and so that there are
ranges the skills we might be better in
some languages and certain aspects of
the language but as a general statement
i would say that if you are an
intermediate a low intermediate you can
say you speak the language if you are a
high intermediate you can say you're
fluent in the language that's my
statement now see what other people have
to say
what do you think about talking to
yourself when you're learning the
language as a way to improve
um you know whatever works
uh
i think
with
you know when i think back now when i
was working on french
i did a lot more of those kinds of
things speaking to myself
uh practicing you know pronouncing
listening to my pronunciation a lot more
sort of deliberate trying to convert
myself into a natural speaker of the
language but now after having learned so
many languages i don't do any of that
i find that just the listening and
reading gets me there now is that
because i am a more experienced language
learner is it because in fact i didn't
really need to do those things
i don't know
but
language learning is this sort of
personal
journey of exploration so i think we
should do all those things whatever we
feel like doing whatever we find
enjoyable as we're exploring and toying
with the language and pursuing different
things in the language
why not do all of these things do things
that you find
work for you
i think the main thing is to stay
engaged with the language doing things
with the language
spending the time remaining motivated so
i have no objective study on which would
show that it's a good thing or not a
good thing to speak
to yourself when you're learning a
language
okay
so that is in so far as the questions if
there are any other questions
uh please let me know
uh i think that's good enough we're
gonna cut it short a little bit today if
there are no more questions
i'm going to go to my arabic
it's a bit of a tough
you know assignment i've given myself
because i
having two languages on the go means a
you have less time to spend on either
one
and b
sometimes you're confused your brain is
a little confused
with two languages going at the same
time on the other hand i do enjoy them
both
and i enjoy going from the one to the
other i'm always reluctant to leave my
arabic to go to persian and then
reluctant to leave my persian to go back
to arabic and yet i look forward to
going to the other one at the same time
so no more questions we're going to stop
it right here and if i can get organized
then on wednesday i'll try and show you
how i use the ipad
all right then bye for now